greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible Q&A I'm your
host my name is Ricky Carter glad that
you could be with us today and we've got
another hour packed program with your
questions your Bible questions and we've
got the answers from the word of God
right here so I've got our panel who's
going to be with us who's going to
answer those questions and let me
introduce them to you right now to my
right we have Pastor densey welcome
brother it's a blessing to be here and
you know the Bible says that it's a lamp
to our feet and a light unto our path it
still is amen amen that's right that's
right and then to his right we have
Pastor rafy welcome brother good to be
here Ricky looking forward to the
questions and the answers God is going
to give us through the holy spirit amen
amen exactly you know when we study
God's word we want to make sure that we
invite the Holy Spirit pray to the Lord
to give us an anointing to help us
understand his word so why don't we go
before the Lord right now in prayer
Pastor RFID could you lead us in prayer
please yes let's pray father we just
want to pause in your presence for
ourselves and for our viewers we want to
ask for that promised gift of the Holy
Spirit John chapter 14 chapter 16 that
the holy spirit will be sent to lead us
into truth to convict us of
righteousness sin and judgment to show
us things to come to answer our
questions father we just give you this
time we give you the viewers we give you
this program and we ask that you'll be
with each question that you'll lead
guide and direct our hearts and our
words and we pray in Jesus name amen
amen amen amen amen well brother deny
before I give you your first question I
want to remind our viewers at home how
you can participate with Bible Q&A you
can do so in one of three ways you can
send us an email to 3abn or excuse me
Bible QA
3abn.org 618 228 3975 that's 618 228
3975 and then for those of you who are
on Instagram you can send us your
questions in that way at
3abn official at 3abn official and also
have you heard about our website where
you can get your Bible questions
answered 3abn Bible anwers.com have you
heard of that site that's a wonderful
site where you can get a lot of your
questions answered can get your
questions answered about daniiel and
Revelation or on health and diet there's
even a question on there I saw there
answers like can we know who the
Antichrist is wonderful questions that
people have sent in and there's all
there on our site 3abn Bible anwers.com
so check it out all right amen Pastor
deny want me give you your first
question why does it look like God is
silent in our moments of need and that
was sent to us from Ghana and they sent
to to us via
Instagram okay thank you very much for
your question and you know this is um
this is an a good question
because uh all of us go through
difficulties and situations that we ask
ourselves where is God why am I going
through this and sometimes we may think
that God is not there but you know God
has promised uh in different ways to let
us he's tried to let us know in
different ways that he is there so I
want to look at a few of
these notice what it says in Hebrews
chapter 5:6 let your conduct be without
covetousness be content with such things
as you have for he himself has said I
will never leave you nor forsake you
amen here we have this beautiful promise
that God says I will never leave you nor
forsake you and then verse 6 says so we
may boldly say the Lord is my helper I
will not fear what can man do to me I
want to uh say this because uh it is
true that Satan Works Upon Our feelings
and we may feel this way or that way and
we may feel alone we may feel
discouraged and he works on those things
to make us think that God is not with us
and sometimes he will feed thoughts into
our mind like uh let's say you walking
out the door you St your toe and then
you go out the door and you drop
something maybe you dropped something
you were eating or something you were
drinking and then you said this is going
to be a horrible day and you think God
is not with you but God has promised to
be with us always even till the end of
the world Amen and so what should we do
uh you know uh we need to look at the
past of God has helped us in the past to
understand that whatever situation we
are going through now he's going to help
us he's going to be with us and that's
why I read Psalms
46:10 be still and know that I am God I
will be exalted among the Heathen I will
be exalted in the earth he is there he
will be with you I encourage you to
encourage you to continue to trust in
him you know look when you look at the
Psalms you see that David went through
times where he's wondering Lord where
are you why aren't you helping me what's
going on please don't be silence help me
and one of those is found found in
Psalms 83:1 keep not silence oh God hold
not thy peace and be not still oh God
help me you can continue reading and you
can see that as before the psalm ends he
he starts to say and yes the Lord is
with me He Will Carry Me Through you
know he uh you see David struggling but
you see him also uh glorifying God in
the situation but please understand that
Romans chapter 1:1 17 as in other place
it says for in it the righteousness of
God is revealed from Faith to Faith as
it is written the just shall live by
faith so we must live by faith not by
sight not by feeling and you
know the promises of God are there so
many beautiful promises that when we're
going through difficult times uh we
should know that God is with us look at
Psalms 46 ver1 God is our refuge and
strength and what and he uh as it says
actually I need to look it up all of a
sudden in time of trouble present help
in time of trouble thank you very much
Escape me for a moment very present help
very present help in time of Trava John
15:7 notice this if you abide in me and
my words abide in you you will ask what
you desire and it shall be done for you
so in these times of Darkness remember
that he has helped you in the past he
will help you again amen I leave you
with Isaiah 41:10 fear not for I am with
you be not dismayed for I am your God I
will strengthen you yes I will help you
I will uphold you with my righteous
right hand God bless you hang in there
God is with you amen amen the Lord is
good he's faithful he's faithful yes
just like you said hold on to the
Lord okay pastor Raff I've got your
first
question please explain and oh this is
your opportunity for a five minute
answer
okay please explain what the Bible says
about interracial marriage that was said
to us from Lisa from Canada and she
texted that to us well Lisa that's a
great question and a rather fast answer
to what the Bible says about interracial
marriage is
nothing at least nothing that forbids it
as we just discussed uh in a previous
question um well we haven't discussed it
in a previous question yet but we're
going to discuss in a in a comc coming
question God's blessing is in marriage
and the Bible is all about marriage and
the Bible wants us to be equally yolked
together in our spiritual belief but God
never makes an issue about race unless
it involves character and spirituality
so interracial marriage is touched on in
a few places though in the Bible and
we're going to see one example of this
in the life of Moses it's kind of a
snapshot we'll look at a snapshot anyway
in in Numbers Chapter 1 veres 1-15 and
that's why this is my five minute
question because it's a long section of
scripture but just let's just read it
and then we'll analyze it then Mariam
and Aaron spoke against Moses because of
the Ethiopian woman which he had married
for he married an Ethiopian woman so
they said has the Lord indeed spoken
only through Moses has he not spoken
through us also and the Lord heard it
now the man Moses was very humble more
than all men that were on the face of
the Earth suddenly the Lord said to
Moses Aaron and Miriam come out you
three to the Tabernacle of the meeting
so the three came out and then the Lord
came down in a pillar of cloud and stood
in the door of the Tabernacle and called
Aaron and Miriam and they were both went
forward and he said hear now my words if
there is a prophet among you I the Lord
will make myself known to him in a
vision I will speak to him in a dream
not so with my servant Moses he is
faithful in all my house I speak with
him face to face even plainly and not in
dark sayings and he sees the form of the
Lord why then were you not afraid to
speak against my servant Moses so the
anger of the Lord was aroused against
them and he departed and when the cloud
departed from above the Tabernacle
suddenly Miriam became leprous as white
as snow then Aaron turned toward Miriam
and there she was a leper so Aaron said
to Moses oh my Lord please do not lay
this sin on us in which we have done
foolishly and which we have sinned
please do not let her be as one dad
whose flesh is half consumed when he
comes out of his mother's womb so Moses
cried out to the Lord saying please hear
heal her oh God I pray then Moses said
Lord then the Lord said to Moses if her
father had but spit in her face she
would not be uh would she not be shamed
seven days let her be shut out of the
camp 7even days and afterward she may be
received again so maram was shut out of
the camp for seven days and the people
did not Journey till maram was brought
again brought in again and that's
numbers again 12 1-15 you saying well
what does this story have to do with
interracial marriage well it has a lot
to do with interracial marriage it's
probably the the only clear
understanding of interracial marriage
that we have in the Bible there are some
really significant insights here
regarding how God R views race and we
know that God has no problem with Moses
Maring in an Ethiopian woman and we know
this for several reasons number one
God's answer to mariam's complaint about
him Marrying an Ethiopian woman is that
hey I speak to Moses Faith to Faith face
to face in other words if I had a
problem with this marriage I would have
told him directly he's faithful in other
words and it's it's important to
recognize when God says that Moses has
been faithful that would include his
marriage God would have brought it up if
it was an issue number two in fact God
did tell Moses directly what he expected
from his people regarding marriage and
race was never part of the council right
God told Moses to tell his people what
he expected from them regarding marriage
and race was never part of the
council and then number three we know
race was not an issue because Moses was
never rebuked by God for marrying an
Ethiopian woman and then number four we
also know that God had no issue with
race because it was Mariam not Moses or
his wife who received God's displeasure
in the form of leprosy M and then number
five we also know that God is no racist
or respector persons when it comes to
race because the Bible says so over and
over again in word in example and as we
hear here in Repro for those who make an
issue out of it now this is important
for me I was born to a black father and
a white mother and when I was born in
1962 race was an issue in this United
States of America so much so that my
father and my mother never married and
that has altered my life forever now
today that wouldn't happen but in the
60s that's the way the the the way it
was in our culture and it really helped
me to understand that that cultural
issue is not a Biblical issue and I
praise God that he is no respector of
persons and that the races are all one
in his sight amen amen thank you sir all
right well we've got another question
here on marriage and this one is for you
Pastor
deny are all marriages between a man man
and a woman blessed by God what if God
didn't want you to marry that person but
you in ignorance married them anyway
that's from Lisa in Jamaica who texted
that question to us well thank you Lisa
for sending in your question and uh at
first I would like to say that we cannot
say that all marriages between a man and
a woman are blessed by God because not
all people consult God in their decision
to be married amen but all marriages can
be blessed if both people surrender to
him and say Lord take control of our
marriage and help us uh to get along and
to have a happy home uh I would like to
say that you know many people make hasty
decisions they don't consult God hasty
decisions are made uh you can look at
different things in the Bible that will
help you like Solomon you know he had
many wives and concubines but you know I
have heard of people that that get
married while they're drunk and they
don't even remember they got that they
say I do
uh and I've heard people say well what's
what happens in Vegas stays in Vegas it
it's just that not all people consult
God and so this is why uh we can say
that not all marriages are blessed but
they can be if we surrender to the Lord
so when you look at these things and you
ask yourselves because your question
mainly is what if God didn't want you to
marry a person but you say in ignorance
which means you didn't know something
but eventually you come to some
information that helps you understand
wow I made a mistake and I was not aware
of it so what do you do with that and it
makes me wonder if you're considering if
it is you I need to I need to end this
marriage and so to you I would say
please take into
consideration that uh God can help you
in whatever situation you're facing amen
it is true that 2 Corinthians 6:14 says
do not be unequally yolked together with
unbelievers for what Fellowship has
righteousness with lawlessness and what
communion has light with Darkness so uh
perhaps somebody that uh became a
Believer later uh after they were
married and then the other person does
not they're looking at this and say uhoh
I need to end this marriage But please
understand in 1 Corinthians chapter 7 we
are given light concerning this and I'll
begin in Reading in verse 12 here's Paul
and Paul and he says but to the rest I
not the Lord say if any brother has a
wife who does not believe and she is
willing to live with him let him not
divorce her any woman who has a husband
who does not believe if he is willing to
live with her let her not divorce
him for the unbelieving husband is
Sanctified by the wife and the
unbelieving wife is Sanctified by the
husband otherwise your children would be
unclean but now they are holy but if the
unbeliever departs let him depart a
brother or a sister is not under bondage
in such cases but God has called us to
peace
for how do you know a wife whether you
will save your husband or how do you
know a husband whether you will save
your wife so serious thought and
consideration should be taken before uh
you make a decision to be married pray a
lot pray a lot and uh ask the Lord for
wisdom you know i' I've heard that if
you're accustomed to praying one hour a
day when you're considering marriage you
should pay pray 2 hours a day because
this is such a serious serious decision
is going to impact your life every
single day of your life so this is why
uh serious consideration needs to be uh
put into this and also consult the Lord
so if you are in a situation where
you're wondering if you should divorce I
would say also to please talk to your
local Pastor uh and let him know what
your concerns are and uh he will give
you some guidance from the scripture
but if you are in a situation where
there's abuse there's abuse and you're
being verbally abused or or beaten uh
you should consider separation until you
see some change in the person and
there's not going to be any change until
that person gives his heart to the Lord
amen thank you for that answer and for
that cancel brother deny okay pastor afy
I got your next question
here can you explain Matthew
16:28 it says some of you standing here
right now will not die before they see
the son of man coming in his kingdom
that's from Eva and she sent that to us
from California and she texted that to
us hi Eva and that is such a good
question you know this is one of those
Bible texts that can be easily
misunderstood some would even suggest
that Jesus predicted that by the time he
would come the second time some of his
disciples would still be alive
and most questions like this can be
easily understood with further
clarification from the Bible in this
case we're going to find the answer in
the context of this question in fact
it's going to be in the very next
chapter let's just pick up in the verse
in Matthew 16:28 surely I say unto you
Jesus said there are some standing here
who shall not taste death till they see
the son of man coming in his kingdom now
notice the very next chapter verse one
now after six days Jesus took Peter
James and John his brother LED them up
to a high mountain by themselves and
when he was transfigured before them his
face Shone like the sun his clothes
became White as light and behold Moses
and Elijah appeared to them talking with
him then Peter answered and said to
Jesus Lord it is good for us to be here
if you wish let us make here three
Tabernacles one for you one for Moses
and one for Elijah now while he was
still speaking Behold a bright Cloud
overshadowed them and suddenly a voice
came out of the cloud saying this is my
beloved Son in whom I'm well pleased
hear him and when the disciples heard it
they fell on their faces and were
greatly afraid but Jesus came and
touched them and said arise and be not
afraid and when they lifted up their
eyes they saw no one but Jesus only now
as they came down from the mountain
Jesus commanded them saying tell the
vision to no one until the son of man is
risen from the the dead so there are
seven points here that help us to
understand what Jesus was saying in
Matthew 16 and: 28 seven points first of
all Jesus is talking about seeing a
vision of his second coming he's telling
the disciples that there are going to be
some of them there they're going to see
him come the second time in vision and
in this Vision we see first of all that
Jesus is glorified we see that the
father is with him and of course we're
told in Matthew 26 and: 64 the father
will be with Jesus when when he comes
the second time he'll be sitting at the
right hand of power three we're told
that Elijah represents the living Saints
1 Thessalonians chapter 4 tells us that
when Christ comes the second time
they're going to be those that are alive
and remain until that coming and then we
see Moses Moses represents those Saints
who are going to be resurrected 1
Thessalonians 4 also tells us there will
be those who are sleeping when Jesus
comes and they'll be raised out of the
grave and we see there that the
disciples also number five fell on their
faces representing what's going to
happen at the second coming coming when
Jesus comes in his brightness many of
those that see him coming are going to
fall on their faces and say hide us from
him that sits on the throne from the
Wrath of the Lamb number six Jesus said
in Matthew 16:28 that some of you are
going to see or remain alive and see my
second coming so notice not all the
disciples saw this Vision three were
chosen James and John James and John
right and Peter and then number seven
Jesus says it was a so difficult verse
to understand unless you see the the
meaning in the context of Jesus is
trying to portray and of course Jesus
explains the meaning in chapter 17 of
Matthew it's a vision that some of the
disciples get to see of his second
coming represented by Elijah those who
are alive when he comes Moses those who
are dead when he comes Jesus is
glorified the father is there and Jesus
Christ confirms exactly what he says in
the previous chapter amen amen and amen
you know that's is a good example of
just reading a little further you know
um and it reminds me of line upon line
precept upon precept we need to study
the word here a little there a little
amen amen all right well brother deny
I've got your third question but before
I share that with you I want to let our
viewers know at home how you can
participate with 3abn today Bible Q&A so
the first way that you can participate
is you can email us you can email us at
bible QA at
3abn.org
here's a long question for you here we
go pastor
my question is regarding tithe and
offerings a lot of overseas workers I
know who lived in a foreign country for
many years give their tithe and
offerings to their home country even
though they don't attend that church
anymore their reason is to help their
church back home as far as I know we are
to give our tithe and offerings to the
church that we are currently attending
because it is the church that nurtures
us and our church family is now we go I
find it confusing because those who give
their tithe and offerings back home even
if they are not there anymore give the
reason they do this do so is that their
Church there will have a high return of
tithes and many more people will be
interested to visit because their church
building is nice and big what is the
right thing to do does it matter or not
as long as we return the tenth to the
Lord what does the bible or our church
say about this matter and that's from
Myra well thank you Myra you have an
interesting concern I must say and what
you are saying sounds logical to me I
see your reasoning and uh I can see why
you would uh think that way and um I
think what has helped me to to consider
this is that uh hearing different stor
and different
experiences uh because some of the
people that you mentioned here are from
other countries and when I think of
countries like India Africa and many
other countries where the poverty level
is so low that the uh local church
congregation cannot even afford a church
building I have heard of people meeting
under a a tree I have seen uh people
just put up things over over their heads
to keep the Sun out and the rain out and
if these people uh know that their
church is in that situation that
condition then I can see them wanting to
uh send their tithe over there to help
them out as a matter of fact I know that
there are some countries where the
people judge how wonderful how great
your God is by the kind of Temple that
you have and if they see you under a
tree they say well your God must not be
a great God if he's so good and powerful
and wonderful why doesn't he provide you
with a tent I specifically heard this in
one of the uh programs that we have here
on 3 AVN so considering this I can see
that some people will want to send their
their tithes away to some other place
but I can also say that the people that
have been gone from that country for 10
years uh they also need to consider the
the needs of the local church and uh
they can they they I would suggest that
they do uh something to help both places
because you're you're like you said
they're being FedEd that Church they
there are local needs at that church
they should bring some offerings to the
church as well you know I want to read
to you uh or to to everyone Malachi CH
3:10 we are told bring all the tithes
into the storehouse that there may be
food in my house and try me now in this
says the Lord of hosts if I will not
open for you the windows of heaven and
pour out for you such a blessing that
there will not be room enough to receive
it so I encourage people to tithe uh
there's a blessing in it and and God is
uh blessing us to the degree that we
should be able to tithe and so when I
mentioned these other countries it came
to mind also a recent well it was
several pictures I was going to say one
picture I saw several pictures of a
church in Cuba the pastor that went
there to do an Evangelistic campaign was
showing me and I saw those and I said
wow they are living uh they're they're
worshiping in a church that you know God
is worthy of better something better
because uh there was actually water
coming in in there and it was it it was
in bad need of repair and and the roof
was leaking and I said wow there are
churches that have greater needs than
they have here in the United States but
still I go back to it uh we should not
we should
not 100% send everything away because
there are local needs as well yeah I was
thinking was you were talking I was
thinking about acts you know remember
when Paul went and took up uh offerings
from all the different churches to bring
back to jerus that's right that's right
because they were in need they were in
need and so he got offerings from all
these churches and brought it back to
the brethren in Jerusalem that's right
amen there a time for that and you know
the Seventh Day Adventist Church is well
organized in such a way that uh there
are tithe is sent away to to help the
the ministry all over the world Amen and
that's that's a great blessing BL amen
thank you thank you gentlemen all right
Pastor rapidy here's your third
question now this is a good one I'm I'm
interested in hear your answer for this
when the righteous go up to meet Jesus
in the clouds what happens when they
leave the Earth do the planes crash if
the pilot was righteous do cars crash if
the drivers were
righteous what happens to the people
that are left on Earth do they die do
they still live or what the people left
on Earth are the unsaved right please
explain and that was emailed to us that
is such a good question and it centers
around an interpretation of the second
coming of Jesus Christ that is based on
what we call the Rapture Theory whether
it's pre Tri or midt or post trip the
idea that when Jesus comes the righteous
will be raptured away and the rest of
the world will continue on as usual and
that really isn't biblical and I'm want
to share three scriptures with you on
this that it's based in first first
Thessalonians chapter 4 by the way and
that's what we want to read to begin
with it says here for the Lord himself
shall descend from heaven with a shout
with a voice of the Archangel with the
Trump of God the dead in Christ shall
rise first the dead in Christ would be
the righteous in Christ and then we
which are alive and remain shall be
caught up now that word caught up is the
same word that we use because in the
English is translated um uh caught up is
translated or in the Greek I should say
it means to seize or to take hold of and
it's translated caught up that's the
word that we use to take out the word
rapture to be caught up to God this is
the word that you're referring to in
your question together with him in the
clouds to meet the Lord in the air and
so shall we ever be with the Lord
wherefore Comfort one another with these
words but just like our previous
question all we need to do is read on
and many times we don't keep reading
let's just keep reading that was 1
Thessalonians 4 vers 16-8 that's the end
of the chapter now let's go to first
Thessalonians 5 and remember there's no
chapter division in the Bible in
original writing Paul is just continuing
on with the same thought same context
everything's the same but of the times
and the seasons breth that is of the
second coming of Jesus you have no need
that I write to you for you yourselves
know perfectly that the day of the Lord
so comes as a thief in the night now
remember this is the same theology the
thief in he's going to come as a thief
in the night and when he comes the
rightous is going to be raptured up
that's what we got so far what's going
to happen to the rest of the people for
when they shall say peace and safety
then sudden destruction cometh upon them
as travails upon a woman with child and
they shall not Escape guess what no one
escapes when Jesus returns right but ye
Brethren are not in darkness that that
day should overtake you as a thief and
when we compare that with second Peter
chapter 3 which also talks about Jesus
coming as a thief notice what it says
here but the day of the Lord 2 Peter
3:10 the day of the Lord shall come as a
thief in the night in the wi the heaven
shall pass away with great noise the
element shall melt with fervent heat the
Earth also shall be be and The Works
thereof shall be burned up seeing then
that all these things shall be dissolved
what manner of persons ought you to be
in all holy conversation and godliness
looking for and Hasting under the coming
of the day of God wherein the heavens
being on fire shall be dissolved and the
element shall mount with fervent heat
nevertheless we according to his promise
look for a new heavens and a new Earth
wherein dwells righteousness and then
Matthew
24:27 excuse me 37 to 41 as in the days
of Noah so also shall be the coming of
the son of man for in the days of Noah
they Before the Flood they were eating
and drinking and marrying and giving him
marriage until the day that Noah entered
the Ark and knew not until the flood
came and took them all away so shall
also the coming of the son of man be
then shall two be in the field one shall
be taken the other left two shall be
grinding in the mill one shall be taken
the other left and the disciples ask him
where where are they going to be taken
he says where you see the carcass there
also shall the bodies be and or the
Birds be in other words in this context
there's no one remaining and you can
read that in Revelation 20: 4 to 5 we
don't have time to read those texts but
there's no one remaining so when Jesus
comes the second time everyone's made a
decision for against God there's not
going to be a pilot flying a plane and a
bunch of people in the plane that could
be saved and are going to be lost
everyone and everyone on planet Earth
whether they're in a plane at the time
or in a car wherever they are they're
either going up or their life is ending
and they're going to stay dead until
after the Thousand Years of judgment and
then the resurrection of the wicked
takes place amen amen correct correct
thank you sir excellent all right Pastor
deny here's your fourth
question how many opportunities did
Satan have to be
forgiven humans were told to forgive our
brothers 70 *
7 so how and why was Satan totally cut
off that's from Anthony who sent it to
us who texted that to us from Canada
that's a very good question thank you
Anthony and this is a good question uh I
will try to get both get to both
questions because there are really two
uh please know that he was given plenty
of opportunity God uh is so merciful so
wonderful uh I think of first Jeremiah
313 uh the Lord has appeared of old to
me saying yes I have loved you with an
Everlasting Love Therefore with loving
kind kindness I have drawn you the Lord
loved Lucifer with everlasting love amen
didn't want him to to to fall away to
sin because he loved them so much so God
made every effort possible that only
Divinity could come up with to uh help
Lucifer not give um complete uh growth
to the little idea that came into his
mind uh that first was a thought and
that eventually mature to I will set my
throne above the Stars I will be like
the most high high before getting to
that God tried to reach and remember
second uh Peter 3:9 uh the last part
says God is not willing that any should
perish but that all should come to
repentance and we can learn about God
about how the way God dealt with Lucifer
from the way God deals with his people
uh you can see some evidence of this in
Genesis for example chapter 4 notice how
he dealt with Cain uh beginning in verse
three and in the process of time it came
to pass that came brought an offering of
the fruit of the ground to the Lord Abel
also brought of the firstborn of his
flock and of their fat and the Lord
respected Abel in his offering but he
did not respect Cain in his offering and
Cain was very angry and his countenance
fell now notice that in this condition
of his countenance Fallen God comes to
him and he talks to him he says so the
Lord said to Cain why are you angry and
why has your countenance Fallen if you
do well will you not be accepted and if
you do not do well sin lies at the door
and its desire is for you but you should
rule over it so God is trying to help
Cain deal with his anger to not go any
further with his anger but we see that
Cain didn't listen later he kills his
brother Abel so God is concerned about
our countenance being fallen so
Lucifer's countenance is Fallen
wondering why am I not getting worship
and adoration I I can see the way he
came to Cain that he came to Lucifer and
tried to help him with uh understanding
his thoughts and his feelings now uh
also I want to point out to you Jeremiah
5:3 notice again God's dealing with his
people it helps us understand how he
dealt with Lucifer oh Lord are not your
eyes on the truth you have stricken them
but they have not grieved you have
consumed them but they have refused to
receive correction they made their faces
harder than Rock they have refused to
return so as God tried to reach Lucifer
he uh refused to receive correction and
uh he made his face hard like a rock and
he refused to turn away from his
thoughts that were just cooking in there
and uh he eventually developed them so
question why was Satan totally cut off
well he had greater and higher
privileges than we do he was next to God
he was the covering Angel he was in the
very presence of God pure Holiness pure
love seeing all of this and yet he
sinned and this is why I go to Hebrews
chapter 6 uh beginning verse four for it
is it is impossible for those who were
once enlightened he was enlightened he
was there in the presence of God and
have tasted the Heavenly gift what more
could he have than uh was already given
to him he had access to all the
wonderful things of heaven and it says
and have become partakers of the Holy
Spirit and have tasted the good word of
God and the powers of the age to come if
they fall away to renew them again to
repentance since they crucified again
for themselves the Son of God and put
him to open open shame that last part
doesn't apply to Lucifer because you
know Jesus Christ was not crucified yet
but you see uh that was his situation
and and God tried to reach him but he
did not can I read one more really quick
here yes yes please okay in Isaiah
chapter 1 verse 4 and 5 uh notice how
the god dealt with the people of Israel
and there's a part here that talks about
Lucifer Allah last sinful Nation a
people Laden with iniquity a a brute of
evildoers children who are Corr
corruptors they have forsaken the Lord
they have provoked to anger the Holy One
of Israel they have turned away backward
why should you be stricken again notice
what it says you will Revolt more and
more the whole head is sick and the
whole heart faint so in essence Lucifer
came to the point he would just if he
was restored we're going to give another
chance no he would Revolt over and over
and over again and God had to cast him
out of Heaven thank you thank you for
the thorough answer all right Pastor
rafid here's your fourth question
if you commit sins again and again does
that mean the Holy Spirit has left you
that's from Emerson who texted that to
us from Texas great question Emerson and
this question actually Builds on the
question we just had um from Pastor John
because it's dealing with the sin
against the Holy Spirit and that's when
the Holy Spirit leaves you and it's what
is known in the Bible as the
unpardonable sin or the sin of blasphemy
against the Holy Spirit God can't pardon
it because we don't confess it if we
confess our he's faithful and just to
forgives our sins but if we don't
confess he can't pardon and that was
Lucifer's problem as Pastor John shared
and that is the problem with sinning and
just let me just throw this in here the
reason why God wants us to stop sinning
is because sin hardens the heart and if
we continue sinning we get to the place
where our hearts become so hardened that
we no longer confess our sins and God
wants to hold us back from that place so
we do not confess it because we're not
responding to the promise promptings of
the Holy Spirit and if we're not
responding to the promptings of the Holy
Spirit which comes to convict us of our
sins and to show us the goodness of God
which leads us to repentance Romans 2:4
and John 16 then it is that we're
committing the uh sin against the Holy
Spirit or we're grieving the holy spirit
of God who convicts us of sin and
righteousness and judgment so the issue
here is not whether we sin again and
again but whether we confess and forsake
our sins right a just man falls seven
times and Rises up again we shouldn't
toy with sin because sin can as Pastor
John was saying sin can Harden our
hearts against confession so let's look
at several Bible verses that explain the
idea I think they explain the science of
confession and victory over sin when we
understand them in how the holy spirit
is active in our life and I call this
the gospel sandwich okay first John
chapter 2 uh vers 8 through1 I'm hungry
right now so I'm I'm in food mode okay 1
John chapter 1 excuse me me 1 John chap
1: 8-10 if we say we have no sin we
deceive ourselves and the truth is not
in us if we confess our sins he's
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and cleanse us from all unrighteousness
if we say we have not sinned we make him
a liar and the word is not in us do you
see the beautiful balance there in this
gospel swich it's like two pieces of
bread don't say you haven't sinned
because you're deceiving yourself and
don't say you haven't sinned because
you're making God a liar but if you
confess your sins he is faithful and
just to forgive us your forgive your
sins and he's going to cleanse you from
all unrighteousness this is the whole
gospel right here it's just power packed
in these three verses from from John and
then he goes on in Chapter 2 1 John
Chapter 2 1 and two and he says if we
sin now I want you to notice the word
there it's really important it's not
when we sin if we sin God is not into US
sinning he doesn't want us to continue
in sin he wants us to overcome sin but
if if we sin we have an advocate with
the father because he doesn't want us to
be overwhelmed by guilt see what happens
is Satan will tempt us and lead us into
sin and then he comes along and he tries
to guilt us to torture us into unbelief
to make us think that God can't forgive
us that we've done this so many times
there's no way God can be merciful
toward us let me tell you God says very
clearly him that comes to me I will in
no wise cast out John 6:37 so if we
confess our sins he's faithful and just
to forgive us if we if if we sin we have
an advocate with the father Jesus Christ
the righteous and he is the propitiation
not just for our sins but for the sins
of the whole world Jesus Christ bore the
penalty the weight of sin for the entire
world read Isaiah 53 very carefully and
he Longs for us to be free from the
burden and the guilt of sin and have
victory over sin he can do this in our
lives we all sin again and again but we
don't all overcome the sin through the
process of conviction of confession of
repentance we all sin but are we all
willing to be forgiven for for our sin
to Humble ourselves and to be cleansed
from all unrighteousness that is the
question Lucifer came to the place he
wasn't willing to do that he wasn't uh
willing and open to confess and to
Humble themselves let's pray that none
of us come to that place through the
grace of God amen amen amen thank you I
like that gospel sandwich that's first
John 1 18-10 so go song there bro amen
yeah let's make that
one all right Pastor deny here's your
last question and have opportunity for a
5-minute
answer what is the meaning of Isaiah 149
and Ezekiel 32:21 and that was texted to
us from
Ghana now this is a question that
requires time uh let's go ahead and read
Isaiah 49 really quick and uh Ezekiel
32:21 it says Isaiah 49 hell from
beneath is excited about you to meet you
at your coming it stirs up the dead for
you all the Chief ones of the earth it
has raised up from their Thrones all the
kings of the Nations Ezekiel 32:21 the
strong among the mighty shall speak to
him out of the midst of hell with those
who help him they have gone down they
lie with the uncircumcised slain By The
Sword it seems to me like you have some
understanding of the state of the dead
and you're wondering well why is this
happening it it appears to say hell but
remember that the word hell in both the
old test and the New Testament in most
cases it is talking about the grave so
what is happening here especially when
you consider Ecclesiastes chapter uh 9
verse 5 and 6 for the living know that
they will die but the dead know nothing
and they have no more reward for the
memory of them is forgotten so this idea
that they don't know anything and uh
they can't have no reward no memory of
anything and now it appears to say that
hell is excited and uh waiting to meet
you it's a question that you have it
says also also their love their hatred
and their Envy have now perished never
more will they have a share in anything
done under the Sun so uh this is the
truth this is the state of the Dead they
can't do anything they can't talk they
can't do anything so what is happening
in Isaiah uh
149 for that we need to go to Isaiah
chapter 144 to help us get a little
context and there we discover the
following that thou shall take up this
problem against the king of Babylon and
say how had the oppressor ceased the
Golden City ceased notice say that he
uses the word proverb and the word
proverb is a Hebrew word that can mean
proverb but it can also mean Parable and
really from Isaiah 14:4 it is a parable
and why because there are several verses
involved when you're talking about a
proverb a proverb is a is a uh a short
message not a long one and here you have
a long message a a a a story a parable
being told with a message in their for
us and so the Hebrew word uh mashal can
mean a proverb and can mean a parable as
well and this word appears about 39
times more than half is talking about a
parable and so a parable is a brief
teaching uh notice what it says in
Proverbs 1:7 this is a proverb the fear
of the Lord is the gning of knowledge
but fools despise wisdom and
instruction but in Isaiah 14:4 we have a
parable uh actually you will notice that
in Psalm
78:2 you will notice that this will
remind you of something Jesus said and
it says I will open my mouth in a
parable I will utter dark sayings of old
Psalm 782 this word Parable is the same
word that was used in uh Isaiah chapter
144 which there it was the word uh
proverb was placed it should be the word
Parable there in Isaiah
144 so what's going on what's Happening
Here is that uh God is giving some
living characteristics to hell and
that's why you see that the uh hell is
excited about you uh to meet your coming
really does the grave get excited about
who's coming no because the grave is an
inanimate uh place there is no life in
the grave and the grave itself cannot
stimulate or wake up or or call anybody
to action so this is a parable for a
teaching and what we get out of this is
that here in Isaiah chapter 14 God is
saying I am going to punish the wicked
I'm going to punish you Babylon for the
things you have done and uh the way
whatever you sow you will reap and this
is really what is is being brought out
in Isaiah chapter 14 so when you go to
Ezekiel CH 32:21 we're dealing with the
same type of thing where God is using
personification and even inanimate
things to help us understand a great
teaching for example there in Ezekiel
32:21 it says the strong among the
mighty shall speak to him out of the
midst of hell with those who help him
they have gone down they lie with the
uncircum uncircumcised slain By The
Sword the here again uh different
nations are said to be in hell you have
uh Egypt and other countries there and
they are said to uh notice ayus there
verse 22 and all her company with their
graves all around them all of them slain
Fallen By The Sword they are dead they
have no participation in anything that
can be done so this can be understood
understanding that the state of the Dead
the they can do nothing that they cannot
talk that they cannot uh have any
participation amen amen thank you sir
thank you all right Pastor Raff here's
your your last question okay can you
please explain Revelation 5:8 and that
was texted to us from um Jamaica Winston
texted that to us great Winston from
Jamaica thank you for the question by
the way just a plug here for salvation
and symbols and SS if you haven't seen
the program we have 114 30 minute
presentations on Daniel and Revelation
and we do cover every verse in a lot
more detail perhaps then I'll be able to
cover this Revelation 5:8 says this and
when he had taken the book
the four beasts and the 4 and 20 Elders
fell down before the lamb every one of
them having Harps and golden vials full
of odors or incense which are the
prayers of the Saints now what we're
seeing here is a picture in the bigger
framework of Revelation four and five is
a picture of the Plan of Salvation and
in this context Jesus Christ is the only
one that's been able to take this book
or scroll out of the right hand of him
that sits on the throne it's sealed up
with Seven Seals and that scroll or book
represents the the title lead to planet
Earth Jesus Christ has redeemed Us by
his blood from the enemy of death and
that enemy is going to be destroyed
because Jesus Christ has gained the
victory over death through his
resurrection and so when this picture is
presented in heaven the four living
creatures that's what they're called in
the Greek and that's what they're called
in some translations the four beasts the
four living creatures and the 24 Elders
Fall Down and Worship Him the four
living creatures are representatives of
the Angels the unfallen angels of heaven
and we know this because we see the same
picture in other places in the Bible for
example in Isaiah chapter 6 and in uh uh
Daniel chapter 7 as well as in Ezekiel
chapters 1 and two these living
creatures these four beasts are
represented as angels as cherub so we
have the Angels here falling down and
worshiping God they are excited about
what Jesus Christ has accomplished but
then we also have in the context of this
we have the 24 Elders now the 24 Elders
are not in Isaiah chapter 6 the 24
Elders are not in Ezekiel chapters 1 and
2 the 24 Elders are not in Daniel
chapter 7 the 24 Elders are a new group
they've never been seen been seen in
heaven before and in the context of this
these 24 Elders are actually the
representatives of humanity these are
human beings that have been taken to
Heaven by Christ and they also fall down
and they even confess in the next verse
that they've been redeemed from um by
the blood of Christ ration Kinder tongue
and people and they have the prayers of
the Saints they have incense which
represents the prayers of the Saints in
other words they're already entering
into a Ministry with Christ in heaven
interceding in behalf of us on planet
Earth that's what we're called to do we
are called to be priests and kings in
Revelation 1:6 and this this is exactly
what they are we're going to be Kings
they are already there they've received
the crowns they've received the Thrones
they've received the white reignment
according to Revelation chap 4 and
they're ministering with with Christ in
our behalf as are the Angels when we
pray Angels minister in our behalf and
we know that humans minister in our
behalf because Jesus Christ was
ministered to when he was a human by
Moses and elishah two of the only three
human beings that are in heaven right
now other than of course these 24 Elders
they came and ministered to Christ they
interceded for Christ so that's the
picture we see here this beautiful
picture of redemption in Jesus Christ
and the part that we play in that
Redemption and the part the Angels play
in that Redemption amen amen thank you
for that answer and thank you both for
all your answers amen we've found a lot
of great answers in the word of God and
I just want to encourage you continue to
read God's word that's where you'll find
the answers hey we're going to take a
short break but we'll be right back so
don't go
away if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us use using God's holy word to shed
light on those texts that seem difficult
to understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org in Bible Q&A for answers from
God's word welcome back well our time is
almost up but before we go let's talk to
our panelists and get some final
thoughts Pastor John I would like to
share you know I'm I'm thinking of the
uh person from Ghana that says why is
God silent when we're in our greatest
needs I'm looking at Isaiah 25 it it
where it says for you have been a
strength to the poor a strength to the
needy in his distress a refuge from the
storm a shade from the heat for the
blast of the terrible one is at a storm
against the wall and Isaiah 26 3 and 4
really quick you will keep him in
perfect peace whose mind is stayed on
you because he trust in you trust in the
Lord forever for in Jehovah the Lord is
Everlasting strength so I say to you
from Ghana or whoever it is wherever you
are trust in the Lord stay close to him
and he will give you that perfect peace
amen amen Pastor ra I'd like to share
with the person who asked the question
about what's going to happen when we go
to meet the Lord in the air it came
through an email you know pilots and
cars crashing etc etc and I think part
of the issue with this is that a lot of
people assume that the Lord is going to
come as a thief in the night and the
Bible doesn't actually teach that the
Bible says the day of the Lord is going
to come as a thief in the night and we
read that in the verses that we looked
at 1 Thessalonians 5 and 2 Peter chapter
3 the day of the Lord will come come as
a thief in the night and there is a
difference MH people will not know when
Jesus is coming in fact we've been told
we don't know the day or the hour when
Christ comes but when he comes they will
know just like if a thief comes to break
into your house you may not know when he
comes to pray on you but once he's there
you know amen so we will know when Jesus
comes amen amen amen all right folks
well I hope you were blessed by all
these answers I want to encourage you to
hide God's word in your heart be strong
and up good courage do not be afraid nor
be dismayed for the Lord your God is
with you wherever you go Joshua 1 19 God
[Music]
bless